but the one thing I found interesting
too is that I think younger people
contribute the most to web content right
they're the ones posting YouTube videos
and blogging and the senior citizens
aren't doing that so in our film when we
did the YouTube competition the seniors
pairing up with young people to create
YouTube videos it was a really great way
for the seniors to have a voice online
which I don't think they do I mean
everything you see is posted by
primarily younger people right so we
really wanted to encourage them to you
know post videos of what can you teach
me what can you teach the younger
generation right yeah i mean sure as
video was just so much fun and i'll save
that for people to watch the film how
competitive did they get with each other
or how invested they become in these
likes and comments and the views because
people you know even in their 40s that
post videos it becomes this huge thing
you know you want to read what people
have written you want to see how many
views does it have how did they react to
that some seniors got very competitive
during the YouTube competition and
you'll see that in the film and it was
funny to see I mean sure you know gets
kind of caddy about the other videos and
just constantly updating your status
looking for more views she was loving
the attention because it was her kids
and grandkids who were then posted on
their Facebook going this is my grandma
check it out she was loving it and some
people thought you know that wasn't a
good thing to put in the documentary
because it shows kind of the dark side
of the internet that you know it can
make you slightly narcissistic because
you're just craving all its attention
but um I just thought it show that you
know she's just like anybody else she
was just like the teenagers who wanted
the hits on the videos I just thought it
was kind of funny the tables had turned
yeah I think that's interesting because
I saw that too and I loved how she was
always so well put together camera is
she's had these incredible outfits on
and and it did show that maybe it's just
part of human nature that we want that
praise and that attention and whether
you're 89 or you know 15 you know you
still want that I thought that was a
great thing and then with the
competition what ended up happening for
the people that didn't win how did they
take it were they able to kind of dust
it off or
yeah there was slight disappointment
there was one video that was really
popular but it didn't win one of the top
three prizes it was Ehlert's video and
then yeah he was a little bit upset
which I didn't expect cuz he didn't care
that much about the competition while I
was going on then we were announcing
winners and you see his face draw a
little bit sad but he knew he had a
great video it still has you know some
of the most hits of all the videos that
we have posted online so
you